it's a momentous year for our favorite
British royal here's a look at the most
regal moments of 2018
congratulations in April willing Kate
welcomed their third child Prince Louis
and we swooned over this first snap of
Princess Charlotte with her new baby
brother but we didn't get a good look
until the palace released this photo for
Prince Charles's 70th birthday isn't he
cute in May we all felt like honored
guests when Harry and Megan tied the
knot there was Megan's jaw dropping Sola
walked down the aisle
Harry's infamous lip fight right before
he whispered you look beautiful to his
bride and who can forget when the
newlyweds shared not one but two loving
kisses but it was there James bond-esque
departure and ride to the reception that
were still watching over and over
[Applause]
the royal family was out in full force
to celebrate the Queen's 92nd birthday
in June where Meghan's stunned
during her trooping the colour debut
skipping the traditional long sleeves
for this shoulder bearing number and I
can stress was very formal
it was incredibly beautiful it was
perhaps a little more revealing than I
think we're used to seeing maybe she
wanted to show off her honeymoon tan but
keep calm Megan and the Queen looked
like old buds during her first solo
public event just a few days later and
she and Kate seemed pretty chummy during
their Wimbledon date in July making it
hard to believe her recent rumors that
the duo is feuding then there's George
when he turned five the palace released
this photo in his honor and he gave us
all the fields while frolicking around
his daddy's polo match with little sis
Charlotte per usual she stole the show
and just check out the pics from her
first day of school
meanwhile the PDA continued from Megan
and Harry so much for the trophy the
winner of this polo tournament got a
kiss there was the couple's first royal
tour we learned of Megan's pregnancy the
day they touched down and they gazed
canoed old and cradled their way through
Australia Fiji Tonga and New Zealand the
dynamic duo
also had a bunch of cute moments with
kids like when this little boy was
obsessed with Harry's beard and in
October Prince George and his cousin
Savannah Phillips became our favorite
new duo at princess Eugenie's wedding
then again their friendship has been
pretty adorable all along Kate was the
definition of regal at a state dinner
where the Queen honored her with the
royal family order she chose an
Alexander McQueen gown for the occasion
along with the famous lovers not tiara
and this diamond and pearl necklace
[Music]
and we can't talk fashion without
mentioning the fabulous pants Kate wore
while visiting a Royal Air Force Base
with Prince William's of course there
was also Meghan's regal looked at the
British fashion awards where she crowned
her wedding dress designer Claire wait
Keller designer of the year the Royals
rounded out the year with their annual
Christmas cards and we can honestly say
we can't decide which pick we like best
it was a regal year for the royal fan
and we can't wait to see what 2019 has
in store
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]